no the father of the atomic bomb doesn't
pull off any Heights inside dreams but
there are some clear similarities
between Oppenheimer and Inception
director Christopher Nolan himself says
so audiences are gearing up to see
Oppenheimer Nolan's much hyped summer
2023 release but in an interview with
Wyatt Nolan himself seems to be looking
to his past a bit particularly toward
his mind-bending 2010 film Inception the
final sequence from inception is always
a fun discussion Point among film
enthusiasts the film's enigmatic closing
moments Inspire multiple interpretations
the Leonardo DiCaprio's carb truly
resurfaced from the dream world and find
his happily ever after with his kids or
will the dream totem continues spinning
forever and signal that he's really
Stills the most inside a dream that way
when you look at your totem you know
beyond a doubt that you're not in
someone else's dream does Kobe even care
after all he's been through Nolan told
Wyatt I mean the end of Inception it's
exactly that there is a nihilistic view
of that ending right but also he's moved
on and is with his kids the ambiguity is
not an emotional ambiguity it's an
intellectual one for the audience the
ending of Oppenheimer is less ambiguous
but is still an unsettling finale Nolan
himself noted the similarities to the
conclusion of inception saying it's
funny I think there was an interesting
relationship between the endings of
inception and Oppenheimer to be explored
oppenheimer's got a complicated ending
complicated feelings and that complexity
is often a trademark of Nolan's work
that threads together his vision from
film to film those who have seen
Oppenheimer have noticed it in his
latest release which is based on the
startling truths revealed in the book
American Prometheus the Triumph and
tragedy of J Robert Oppenheimer it
captures the harrowing reality of the
creation of the atomic bomb two of which
were dropped on the Japanese cities
Nagasaki and Hiroshima by U.S forces
during World War II Nolan's film
explores the ethical boundaries crossed
by the title character who played a
pivotal role in bringing the weapon of
mass destruction to life J Robert
Oppenheimer was even dubbed the father
of the atomic bomb for his Central
involvement and research search in the
initiative to build the A-bomb the
Manhattan Project Nolan told wired of
his new film some people leave the movie
absolutely devastated they can't speak I
mean there's an element of fear that's
there in the history and they're in the
underpinnings but the love of the
characters the love of the relationships
is as strong as I've ever done that
strong character development would seem
to strengthen the comparison to
Inception along with the fact that both
films have Killian Murphy in the cast he
plays a title character in Oppenheimer
Nolan took a complex fascinating
approach to telling the story of
Oppenheimer speaking with total film he
shared that he's set out to record the
historical events depicted in the film
through J Robert oppenheimer's eyes
making the otherwise straightforward
historical drama more personal Nolan
said we're trying to tell the story of
somebody's life on their journey through
personal history and larger scale
history and so the subjectivity of the
story is everything to me in the case of
this film I wrote the script in the
first person it's the only time I've
done that New England's
character-centric view definitely had an
effect on Murphy the director added we
want to view these events through
oppenheimer's eyes and that was the
challenge for Killian that I set him to
take us on this journey Nolan noted that
Murphy's challenge extended to pretty
much the entire team behind the movie
every choice made had to somehow Circle
back to oppenheimer's perspective on the
world drawing such a turbulent yet
pivotal point in history Oppenheimer
opens on July 21st
foreign